[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes i'm katie balls the spectator's
deputy political editor and your host
this week
on the show today
austria germany and the czech republic
have enforced selective lockdowns
ladders locked down to people who don't
want to take the covert vaccine
is this fair phrasal debate an oxford
medical ethics professor
is boris losing his sheen james forsyth
and jeremy vine will be on the show to
tell us what they made of that cbi
speech
then we'll head across the channel
freddie gray spoke to eric zamor the
french presidential candidate at the
weekend does he pose a serious challenge
to macron
then we'll look to china a tennis player
peng shui seem to have gone missing but
she has re-emerged in a series of
so-called proof of life videos
is the west making a deal out of nothing
we'll speak to vince cable and cinder
you
and finally what makes a classic book in
a few years might sally rooney be on the
list of classics of our generation or
not
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv do subscribe to our youtube
channel just click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of the video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
first is the lockdown the unvaccinated
ever justified in this week's cover
piece ross clark looks at the protest
starting across europe because of the
threat of another lockdown
fraser nelson editor of the spectator
joins me now together with dominic
wilkinson a professor of medical ethics
at the university of oxford
fraser ross writes about lockdowns for
the unvaccinated in europe and to start
what is happening on the continent right
now
well the cover situation is getting
quite significantly worse austria's seen
the steepest increases we're now seeing
um hospitals fool yet again very
familiar stories at this time last year
the difference being that we had thought
in the summer that britain was getting
the worst of it and that the europe
continental europe seemed to be
relatively clear
this goes to show that covet keeps
surprising us and now we're getting the
same conversations in the continent
whether to lock down or not but also
whether to have lockdowns of the
unvaccinated this was austria's
innovation a couple of weeks ago and the
political language in the continent is
changing also quite significantly
there's now a phrase which is being
heard in in germany in bavaria and the
czech republic but this is a pandemic of
the unvaccinated in other words that the
trouble is being brought um to the
countries by people who are refusing to
get vaccinated
and now this is beginning to collide in
a very interesting and rather alarming
way with existing political divisions in
europe in germany for example the
unvaccinated
disproportionately tend to live in
east germany and votes for afd the kind
of the far-right populist group and the
afd so you're seeing this kind of
overlap
between what we would typically regard
as far-right populists fairly or
unfairly and people who are now
complaining about vaccine mandates and
the overall issue of civil liberties and
that's something that nicolas farrell
looks at in this week's magazine the
paradox of fem parties that can pretty
much genuinely be called fascist com
campaigning in the cause of liberty
against the left-leaning centrists who
are i guess against and the civil
liberty argument and more in favor of
lockdowns and compulsory vaccination so
we're seeing very strange dynamics but
as ross argues in his cover piece it
seems to be merging very quickly into a
kind of culture war and it's not just in
the british press that's making this
point and henrik broder has written a
very good piece in in divelt today in in
german where he makes the point that the
language now is almost as if you're
talking about the heretics the witches
the deserters the kind of a subset in
society on whom our woes can be blamed
he says that politics gets into a very
dangerous place when the debate goes
down that line and that's what we're
seeing the debate slide into in the
continent
now dominic fraser mentions the fact
that this is almost being referred to as
the pandemic of the unvaccinated in
certain countries and austria's decision
and they're probably the first to have
this idea of a lockdown just for the
unvaccinated do you think that raises a
moral dilemma
well there is a series of moral dilemmas
that we've faced across the pandemic
broadly speaking one of them that
that we're seeing raising intent again
is is that
the balance between
safeguarding well-being and health of
the population and protecting the
liberties of individuals to make
decisions for themselves and to go about
their normal lives
um
there's also a kind of third factor
which is about treating people equally
so we've we've referred to this as a
pandemic trilemma of choices between
freedom
uh health or mortality uh and equality
and you can't have all of those values
you make your choices and then you get
the results uh
both in terms of
uh
the ethical values that you sacrifice
and of course the the impact on on
population and on excess mortality
and doubling on that do you think that
you it is more morally justifiable to
have uh you know a lockdown just for the
unvaccinated if you're thinking about
you know the greater good to say
so in terms of uh lockdowns and
selective lockdown selective lockdowns
are in effect just
an extension of what has been debated
for some time which is the notion of
vaccine passports
and basically that's about treating
people differently based on
their risk of transmission of the virus
and and prior to that that whether or
not they've had the vaccine
now there's a variety of questions about
that is that is this an effective way of
managing the vaccine is it proportionate
to the risks
at stake is it necessary are there other
ways around it though those three issues
effectiveness proportionality and
necessity are key ethical considerations
in working out whether this is
appropriate it's useful to think about
the alternative so
if you're
if you've got a massive spike in cases
as they're seeing in some parts of
europe
and
your health system is seriously under
threat the alternative is to institute a
generalized lockdown as indeed some
european countries
are having to at this point in time or
to say
we're going to spare from that lockdown
those who are at lower risk
of ending up in hospital or of
transmitting the virus
for many the the idea of a selective
lockdown will look more attractive than
bringing the whole community again to a
screaming halt and sending everybody
back to their zoom offices and
uh and their homes
fraser do you agree with that it's a
more attractive proposition
uh no i do think the level of social
segregation the vaccine passports and
selective lockdowns proposes is a really
deeply disturbing notion
again we need to look at who's on the
right and the wrong side of this vaccine
divide in britain if you're poor you're
far more likely to be unvaccinated than
if you're rich if you're black you're
something like three or four times more
likely to be vaccinated than if you're
white now it's not entirely clear why
these m divisions are full in the way
they have done but there's no diet
denying we've got the data this is
exactly what is happening now do you
want to take a society already quite
badly and struck by social divisions and
make these even worse
and is there does the state ever have
any moral authority to deprive from the
certain section of society for civil
liberties i'm not sure that's the case i
think the argument for lockdowns to be
honest is borderline but if you are
going to um apply them to apply them to
everybody at least is better than
targeting people who you rightly or
wrongly think pose a greater risk
because let's remember that the um the
argument here is taken on the premise
that the unvaccinated pose a far greater
risk when the vaccinated but that when
you look at it and drill down that
evidence is far more shaky than you than
you might think in ross's cover piece
for example he um i'm just reading it
here he talks about this this german
study um which um shows that 80 percent
of those refusing to be vaccinated don't
have a problem with vaccination
in general they're just concerned about
the safety
implications of this particular vaccine
is that um is that necessarily a wrong
and indefensible and position
and also when you look at the data for
who passes on infections then it's far
more difficult to say about the
unvaccinated pose a far greater threat
when they're vaccinated because if you
are vaccinated you're far less likely to
get ill yourself you're far less likely
to end up in hospital if you look at the
hospital figures overwhelmingly the icu
units are full of those who didn't get
vaccinated but when it comes to passing
on the virus
then the studies show it's pretty murky
that it simply isn't the case but if you
take the vaccine you're not going to
pass it on and if you don't have the
vaccine you do and also let's remember
there's a third category i think this is
quite important that the third category
of people who haven't who haven't had
the vaccine but have had the virus now
there's a study recently showing that
previous natural immunity is a lot more
reliable than vaccinated immunity so if
somebody has had covetous been in bed
for two weeks with coveted or worse then
that person really is i'm very unlikely
to pass it on so why ethically would you
not include them if amongst the people
you're allowed to be given their
liberties with and also the other
ethical dilemma here and i'll be
interested to to hear your thoughts on
this is
what say you're going to fire somebody
if you're not taking the vaccine this is
what the british government has done
with care home workers no jab no job
that's been the rules um now when i
asked sajid javed about this health
secretary a few weeks ago he said that
he basically it would be a concession he
doesn't want to make a concession to
those who believe anti-vaxx propaganda
now that's uh one category of people but
what about the category people who do
not you absolutely believe in
vaccination but cannot see what medical
advantage you take from being vaccinated
if you're already naturally immune a
vaccine which let's remember could save
a life of somebody in the third world
who hasn't yet been offered it so that
category of people morally can you
really fire them if you can't argue but
they pose a covert threat or a greater
covert threat than people who haven't
had the virus but have not been already
been vaccinated so those of you is far
more complicated in the real world than
the theoretical exercises are making out
and that's why i think you're seeing
protests in europe right now people just
reject the rather
facile way in which vaccine passports
and lockdowns for the unvaccinated are
being sold
so so it's useful here to see one kind
of
area of obvious agreement between us
which is about the
the importance of
focusing on what's ethically relevant
uh so in in terms of transmission of the
virus that what's relevant is is an
individual's risk of transmitting the
virus and of course if they have had a
vaccine or if they've
been unfortunate enough to have the
infection and then have recovered they
potentially are at equivalent risk and
ought to be then
treated equivalently either both locked
down or are both allowed to go about
their normal lives so that i think is uh
one of the reasons why
on the continent many of the vaccine
passport schemes and suggestions in
terms of selective lockdowns
have treated those who have the
vaccination and those who've recovered
from covid
similarly
the uk approach in terms of mandatory
covered vaccination for care home staff
or nhs workers hasn't taken that
approach and i and others have
criticized the government i totally
agree that it's not fair to to remove
somebody from their job on the basis
that they
they haven't had a vaccine
where they've got evidence they can
there is reasonable evidence that uh
that they've had an infection and are
not at risk of passing on the virus that
they can prove their antibodies for
example that's a fairly easy way of
doing it so antibodies or they've had a
positive pcr test within within a period
of six months and indeed that's already
recognized in terms of nhs covert pass
so there's already a structure for doing
that does it doesn't seem like there's
any sensible reason why the government
can't couldn't introduce that to their
policy
but in terms of
just stepping back to the this question
of transmission
uh and the the approach in the continent
it's worthwhile recognizing
what's fundamentally
there are two reasons why somebody
should get vaccinated one is for their
own health and their own well-being and
of course when it comes to state
intervention
in somebody's life for their own benefit
that's we understand that that's a
paternalistic intervention and and the
great uh political philosopher john
stuart mill uh has kind of
very clearly encapsulated the notion
that
the only justifiable reason for the
state interfering in an individual's
liberties
is to prevent harm to others harm to the
self is not enough
so
harm to the self for for a individual's
own health is not a good reason for
having a vaccine passport or selective
lockdown harm to others might be now as
you point out the effect on transmission
is not as dramatic as perhaps people had
hoped there is a reduction in
transmission with with vaccination but
it's not as clear as those who are
vaccinated pose no risk of vaccination
those who are unvaccinated and not
immune pose a huge risk there's a
difference but it's not as large perhaps
as we might like but there's a different
way in which the unvaccinated pose a
risk to others health and that's through
getting sick and consuming scarce
resources over winter so the the nhs is
is already despite the fact that
actually we're not facing the enormous
spike of cases
of europe is is already kind of
groaning and creaking and and in danger
of falling over that's how to do this no
well that's that's because of the the
resources is because of the the the
flow on effect of covid and the ongoing
kind of a number of cases that are
affecting your hospital so there's a
combination of factors
but
if you had a further spike of cases with
a a significant number of individuals
who are then becoming critically ill
what you'd then find is that that would
pose a risk to other people both people
without covid who couldn't then get into
hospital have their operations have
their cancer surgery
all the the flow on effects and of
course other people with covid who would
be competing with them for scarce icu
resources
so one of the i think one of the
plausible rationales for a selective
lockdown in europe although
again i i agree it's debatable whether
that's the right
approach on balance but one plausible
basis is to say look if if our hospitals
are at risk of falling over
one way of reducing that avoiding that
is to lock down those who
to prevent them getting sick and then
needing those hospital resources i i
would say there that you need to look at
the science behind this for example how
sure are we but lockdowns really do
serve as this emergency stop which the
theorists imagine that they do if you
look in the british example for example
we have um the the virus was sent into
reverse before lockdowns took place look
at sweden they've had no lockdowns there
and they were twice able to force the
virus into reverse by not resorting to
lockdown not depriving anybody of their
civil liberty so again the arguments
which are pretty sweeping government
powers saying to see you're not allowed
to go to work you're not allowed to go
to the pub you're not allowed to leave
your life you're not allowed to go see
your family
if this is not on a strong scientific
basis then there's really no moral
argument for this at all so right now i
think we're skipping the really
important part which is does the logic
actually work and right now i'm afraid
to say we've had 18 months of lockdowns
very mixed evidence as to whether they
are effective in sweden a demonstration
of how liberal liberal society can keep
its values while fighting back the virus
and overall very important questions
which many of those in the streets are
raising in protests right now
and so i think there are really
important questions
again here about the the effectiveness
of different interventions and then the
proportionality relative to the benefit
i i think i interpret the evidence quite
differently to you that there's very
clear evidence that those countries that
have chosen to lock down have had as a
result a very significantly fewer
overall deaths so sweden has had lower
deaths than some other countries but
it's had very substantially more excess
deaths than its immediate neighbors
neighbors with very similar populations
and and others very very different
urbanization levels so that old i mean
sweden's more organized than britain so
we can't really make that comparison
the uk has had dramatically more exist
mortality than a number of again
relative comparative countries on the
continent
and we looked down more than anybody
pretty much last year well no
i mean our lockdowns were by and large
instituted later less stringently than
than a whole series of other countries
they lasted a lot longer britain is the
case study i'm afraid to say for those
who question the efficacy of lockdowns
in keeping the the death rate down
either amongst us were covered and
importantly amongst the under 65s our
death rate is really quite high by
european standards that implies that the
side effects of lockdown might be
greater than we're looking at so again i
really think we need to be very clear
about the science before we're talking
about depriving anybody off their basic
liberty i mean again so there are
scientific questions important important
questions and then there's ethical
questions so in terms of the science
it's important to look at whether where
the lockdown work whether they cause
more harm than good overall in terms of
how communicating what science would
need to be but really how clear do you
think how sure would we need to be about
this science before we issue lockdowns
and deploy people with civil liberty on
that basis
well
i mean one of the challenges of course
in a pandemic is that you have to make
decisions when the evidence is imperfect
and there's uncertainty
one of the interesting questions uh has
been not simply about whether to lock
down but how much to lock down and when
to lock down of course in the uk we've
chosen to relax lock down earlier
and get anticipating that that would get
a surge in cases
before the winter other countries have
made different choices now perhaps
paying the price for that with now a
surge of cases that coincides with the
winter
and
you have to make decisions in the face
of uncertainty
i don't think it's
we have the luxury of waiting until
there's cast iron evidence uh i think we
have in the uk made a series of mistakes
uh by waiting to make decisions in the
past at the moment i don't think there
is a pressure on on the uk to to make
decisions acutely to lock down or to
selectively lock down again though that
could change
and partly because
the key factor which is about uh health
system
being under significant threat is we
have very little room to move because of
the nature of our health system and its
chronic shortage of resources
thanks fraser and dominic
subscribe to the spectator in our flash
sale and you'll get 12 weeks of the
magazine in print and online for just 12
pounds not only that but we'll also send
you a bottle of johnny walker black
label scotch whisky absolutely free
hurry though as this offer ends on
monday
now coming back to westminster the talk
this week has been on peppa pig a
children's cartoon that the prime
minister waxed lyrical about in a
bizarre speech earlier this week
has he lost his mojo is it all an act or
does he know exactly what he's doing
i'm joined now by broadcaster jeremy
vine he has an incredible boris story to
tell and our political editor james
forsyth
jeremy can you start by recounting that
strange encounter you had with boris
johnson a few years ago
all right this is what happened it was
the international securitization awards
and i was there to hand out the awards
and most unusually they booked somebody
else to do a speech and i and i had no
knowledge in advance of who it was but
it was boris johnson he wasn't at the
time even mayor of london he was just a
humble mp and at about 9 28 he was due
on in two minutes he hadn't arrived it
got to 9 29 and a half and the
organizer's really sweating and she says
where is he i don't know i mean i know
him a bit but i don't know him enough to
know where he is right now and as she
was speaking he suddenly comes in with
this enormous sort of whoosh of blonde
hair disheveled clothes the usual boris
thing he sits down at the table and bear
in mind the second his bum touches the
seat he really should be on stage and
his first sentence is where am i
so i say well you're at the
international securitization awards and
that sign is on the screen there boris
what is what is securitization i'm
thinking we're on borrowed time here
mate because they're about to announce
you so he's very boofed up bankers
explained to him what securitization was
that was a thing by the way that got us
into all the trouble in the financial
crisis
and he then took a a menu and he turned
it over and he started writing his
speech and at this point i'm getting
stressed because i think i don't know if
i could handle this level of of lateness
in my own life or indeed in anyone
else's so all i saw him write on the
piece of paper was was the word shark
and the word sheep that's all i saw and
he was resting the piece of paper on his
thigh
and then they suddenly say ladies and
gentlemen boris johnson and he goes up
but he's left a piece of paper so i
think this will be a disaster and he he
gets on the stage and it's almost like
he's exploded out the stage in one of
those trap door moments with smoke and
everything because he looks so
completely disheveled
and people started laughing at his at
his appearance and he said welcome to
everybody to thee and i've got my head
in my hands because he doesn't of course
know where he is so he has to do the
terrible thing of turning around and
reading the description of the event off
the wall behind him so he said the
international
and he then goes through this speech and
it's clearly it's chaotic so the first
thing he says he's very upset about the
eu
because
basically a sheep died on their farm
this is the sheep story a sheep died on
their farm and they weren't allowed to
bury it on the farm they had to take it
to an abattoir so he rang the abattoir
the person's name there was bill no i
think that one it was derek no no it was
it was clyde no it was margaret it's
muggy everyone starts laughing he then
goes into this ramble about his
political hero is the mayor from jaws
because he kept the beaches open oh come
to think of it some some children were
killed by a shark and then he tells and
this is the thing i think i can't
believe he's doing this he tells a story
which which even people you know who
aren't we weren't born in the 30s have
heard hundreds of times which is about
the foreign secretary george brown
and the fact that he was in peru and
music started and he asked somebody for
a dance and the person said there are
three reasons i can't dance with you the
the first reason is that this is the
peruvian national anthem the second
reason is that i am the archbishop of
lima and the third reason i'm ready for
the third reason and he said i can't
remember the third reason i can't
remember the third reason and it brings
the house down and i suddenly think my
goodness this is extraordinary i'm in
the presence of genius here this guy
has somehow delivered the perfect speech
even though it's fallen apart he's
rescued it and the very last moment is
he he says jeremy vine is not going to
give out the awards but they look like
some sort of elongated lozenge and he's
got a piece of glass in his hand and
then he sits down and i had some funny
remarks prepared and i realized there's
absolutely no point whatsoever in me
saying anything to make anybody laugh
harder than they're laughing now so i
simply did the awards and then i dropped
him a line afterwards on a postcard and
it just said the mayor of jaws brilliant
exclamation mark and he dropped me a
postcard back jeremy you were fantastic
so i didn't i didn't believe the word so
i sort of banked that as oh my goodness
this guy is able
to deliver a brilliant speech with no
preparation and i as a speaker i'm kind
of interested in how that happens
anyway we spilled forwards about a year
18 months
and now i'm at a different event and
it's the national concrete federation
and it's 928 and i say who's the other
speaker and it's boris and he comes in
and i think oh here we go and the but
the thing is what was amazing to me is
it was
everything was the same 929 he arrives
he gets the menu where am i what is it
can i mention concrete or is it cement
he then writes shark and sheep on the
piece of paper he leaves it on the table
he starts the story about the sheep and
the abattoir and it was margaret then
it's the jaws and the the mayor and the
political hero i suppose some young
children die and then the remarkable
thing is this he does the george brown
story and he does firstly i'm the
archbishop of lima and secondly this is
the peruvian national anthem and thirdly
i can't remember the third reason i've
forgotten my own punishment and then he
takes the award and he says it looks
like some sort of elongated lozenge and
i'm looking everyone's roaring with
laughter and
the reason this story went viral when i
retold it was because
i'd written it up as part of a book
about
just whether or not we trust what we see
years ago and of course when he became
prime minister i just put it on my
facebook page and it went across the
world because suddenly we all started
thinking wait is this is this an act or
is it deliberate so i have to admit
katie that when
when he did the thing with his speech it
all came back to me this forgive me
forgive me and then he tells the peppa
pig
and i'm thinking is this it again
has he practiced this
and i i don't know is the answer but
that but there we are the art the
speeches story is so interesting because
it suggested that nothing about boris
was an accident
that's pretty interesting and you
mentioned that cbi speech so jeremy
having seen that and there are lots of
uh very stereotypical miss boris johnson
moments as you say peppa pig almost
losing the place i think most people
thought wouldn't even be put in there to
throw people off the scent um but you're
not conv you you're not decided either
way well that is uh meant to be a
crafted act when he gave that speech or
it really was just a bit of a unplanned
mess i've looked at it now i think 20
times because i want the answer and the
first thing is he has a motive for
having a disheveled cbi speech and the
motive is social care so in the commons
he didn't lose a vote but he came pretty
close with a majority of 20 or whatever
on these plans which it turns out the
social care plans are going to be even
worse for poorer people so what does he
do he gives us some people call it the
dead cat he's going to do a speech where
all we talk about is this weird story
about peppa pig and turning the pages so
there is
there is motive
now i looked when he did started this
thing which is just like the shark sheep
story anyway isn't it which is where he
turns he goes forgive me forgive me i
thought he was holding blank pieces of
paper which would suggest that he'd
somehow engineered this
the second thing is
i remember quite soon after he became
prime minister the incident where he was
interviewed
about what he does in his spare time
and he said i like to build buses i
build big ones i sit there and this bus
story went completely viral and i think
he realized
that with a really lateral story like
peppa pig like the bus he can just take
us to another place and it's really
easily done
so some of it was deliberate
but i think some of it was accidental
and the thing that argues against my
idea that it's all deliberate is this
where when he launched his very first
leadership bid
which was shambolic it fell apart when
he actually arrived on stage remember he
had nadine doris in the front row
and then michael gove suddenly pulled
out
nobody would engineer that
so his mishaps can't all be deliberate
so i think with the cbi we had the peppa
pig story and the vroom vroom stuff i
mean the peppa pig was classic boris
that was deliberate the accident was the
pages i do i mean if the if the pages
was deliberate we are in the presence of
a master
james did tory mps think they were in a
presence of a master right now um does
it feel so boring is getting the best
reception of his party
no i think the most telling thing is
when you watch the clip of that moment
when he loses his place in the speech
on the second and third forgive me i
mean that's one of the first times i've
heard actual kind of fear in boris
johnson's voice i think he actually
realized that he actually really had
lost the place and didn't know how to
start his way out of it now i think
jeremy is right that a lot of the the
the boris persona is contrived it's much
more controlled uh than he wants you to
think but i thought when he lost the
place it was genuine i also think
jeremy talked about a possible political
motive for that i actually that's the
the losing the place happened at the
worst possible moment because the tory
mps who are worried that downing street
was disorganized was chaotic
but losing the place in the speech
became almost a visual metaphor for what
their concerns were and i think it also
made lots of people said why are you
trying to deliver you know a funny
speech to the cbi if there was ever a
place for a for a for a worthy 40
minutes on you know skills training and
infrastructure budgets um
it's the cbi
and and so i think i don't i mean i
think i mean i don't think it was
deliberate but i think if it was
deliberate it it didn't work
you know it's interesting i mean i
there's no doubt boris johnson is
addicted to other people's laughter
there's no question about it and he's
got brilliant it's just the very walking
into the room listen to what jennifer
arkuri says about him he walks in the
room everyone starts laughing you know
so he loves that and remember a lot of
this that the hair famously you know
messes up his hair before interviews and
after makeup which nobody else does but
it was all priced in in the last general
election we you know we knew about it we
knew that when he launched a campaign to
get rubbish out of rivers he would fall
in the river which indeed he did we knew
about the zipwhile we priced it all in
and we gave him an 80-seat majority you
know whichever way you voted that's how
it ended up so i think that i
yes he did i agree with you um james he
def there was definitely a moment of
fear i wonder where there's a little bit
of residual covid lung there where he he
gets more breathless than he needs to be
but i think at the same time he's not in
danger
from boris style mishaps whatever his
party think because
i it's it's it's part of who he is the
danger for him is panicking and doing
all straight lines the whole of covid
has been boris's most uncomfortable
experience because he can't do gags so
at last he's released into being boris
so i think in a way this is better
territory for him
and just finally james uh this week
we've been hearing more grumblings from
tory back benches that speech i think
was definitely seen as another trigger
various briefings one that has
particularly upset certain figures in 10
downing street to the bbc's laura
koonsburg a downing street source
doesn't say which address or which floor
um but how seriously should we take this
how much trouble is the prime minister
in there are whispers of letters going
to the 22 chairman
so i i think tory mps are grumpy and but
i think the biggest danger to boris
johnson is
that this next few months is going to be
really hard if you look at the kind of
economic backdrop rising energy prices
rising inflation the supply chain
sources aren't all sorted out and and
and as jeremy says you know boris
johnson is a good times politician he he
is never more comfortable than when he
can be an optimist and when he can be
funny and he can make people laugh and
smile
i don't think there's going to be that
much smiling in britain in the next few
months i think it's going to be quite a
hard winter i mean that is the biggest
challenge for him and i think the other
biggest challenge for him is is is
detail and whether these policies match
up to what he promised in the first
place i think that there's jeremy
alluded to the row over social care i
think the issue there is you know if
boris johnson has raised taxes to fix
social care once and for all then i
think tory mps could kind of see the
political logic for it but if he's
raised taxes to make some incremental
improvements to social care uh out of
which not everyone is a winner then that
is a very different uh political
situation and there'll be a fair bit of
tory grumpiness about that
jeremy james thank you for joining
spectator tv
next on the show been covering the rise
of eric zamor the journalist turned
unlikely presidential election candidate
over the last weekend our own french
correspondent freddie gray met him in
london they spoke at length about
everything from brexit to immigration to
the culture wars in france the whole
discussion will be up on our youtube
channel it's in french but we subtitled
it for you and here is a short clip
from
um
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
freddie joins me on spectator tv now
freddie tell me what struck you most
about that conversation
uh well i suppose what struck me most
about him was his team who seemed very
very stressed
uh they'd organized this very sort of
hectic tour of london in which zamor was
supposed to come and and meet
as many of the french voters that there
are in london there's hundreds of
thousands of them
here so it's actually quite an important
sort of pit stop for anyone wanting to
be president
uh and zamor did not get a warm
reception it's fair to say sadiq khan
made it very clear that he didn't he
wasn't welcome in london
and the tory party i think um called off
and canceled various meetings that he'd
arranged because he's considered toxic
because of his statements about islam
and immigration so they were a bit
stressed i think they were hoping it
would go
more smoothly than it did
and then as for him himself he was sort
of quite
gregarious i suppose quite charismatic
he's a huge phenomenon in france they
don't know a lot about him in london but
i mean if you talk to i have french
family my mother's french if you talk to
when i talk to my cousins he is the
talking point and so that's why
it seems people say it's like a
trump-like moment in france but it's
certainly true that it's a it's a moment
where he is the conversation starter for
a lot of things
and freddie i suppose more importantly
how is he being perceived in france in
terms of the polls
uh well i mean was pretty well he's had
a slight dip uh but he was coming second
in in some polls in the in the
presidential polls still substantially
behind macron but ahead of le pen which
is the key thing for him is that he
wants to effectively um swallow le pen's
vote and then try and take the
republican the old center right vote as
well
uh
i mean the latest poll suggests that's
had a slight dip but nothing very
significant he is still the the media
story he's all anyone's talking about in
the press
uh because he's a journalist i think and
because he he's a tv he's a person who's
done a lot of tv and he knows what
creates interest and what creates a good
story
do we have any sense of whether macron
is worried even if he is still uh
reality comfortably ahead
uh well i mean
no i don't think mackerel has ever given
any public indication of being concerned
about zamor i think he has said critical
things of him
uh but it's interesting that last year
um no sorry two years ago i think when
zamore was attacked in the street
uh the next day macron rang him to sort
of offer his sympathies
but also to talk through what he thought
zamor had misunderstood about his
leadership so and it's also interesting
that the two men are quite similar um
macron
didn't have a party
uh he invented his own party he sort of
uh swallowed the the center left and the
left to a certain extent
um and the center right to a certain
extent he he made his own political
phenomenon and zamor's trying to do the
same thing and just finally freddie what
do you with your pundit head on um give
zamora's chances when it comes to the
election i'm thinking a little bit
further ahead would you place a bet on
him
well somebody once told me never to make
political predictions and i've always
ignored them too that's what we like on
the show
because
so i will say that my hunch at the
moment is that he will not win
uh i think he has a chance of
getting into the final two it's as a
run-off system in france
uh but i cannot
see him beating macron at the moment but
obviously
france is a very febrile place at the
moment there's a lot of talk about a
sort of coming civil war because a lot
of the
cities are in such a bad way um so
you know it could it could be a very
dramatic election and i just wondered on
that by having some more in the race say
that he you know is not going to win um
is he changing the discourse is he
changing what topics is it meaning that
macron is having to talk about some
things he wouldn't otherwise talk about
or is it more actually than a quran
thing needs to prove that he is even
more the polar opposite
i think macron is pivoting right and he
he probably would have done that without
zamor because
uh the left is in a sort of terrible
state at the moment in france the old
socialist party has has sort of imploded
partly because of mackerel uh there's
melanchol who's the sort of corbin
figure if you like
of france uh but he's not
improving his polling at the moment so
where macron can win votes is by
pivoting to the right and that's by
saying very tough things
about islam
uh in in french cities and by by talking
about immigration in tough terms but
also probably not actually doing that
much in terms of policy so
uh i think
macron knows how to deal with the threat
of more which is to
uh pivot right
freddie thanks very much
subscribe to the spectator in our flash
sale and you'll get 12 weeks of the
magazine in print and online for just 12
pounds not only that but we'll also send
you a bottle of johnny walker black
label scotch whiskey absolutely free
hurry though as this offer ends on
monday next from france to china with a
disappearance of a tennis star and
former mistress to a high-ranking
communist official has led to renewed
calls to boycott beijing's winter
olympics in this week's issue cindy u
covers the peng shui affair and writes
more generally
about the mistress culture in china she
joins me now together with vince cable
former leader of the liberal democrats
and author of china engage avoid the new
cold war
cindy to start can you just tell us
what's going on with this story about
pentroy yeah so this is a tennis player
who has uh had for a while disappeared
after she accused a former chinese vice
premier of
a three-year affair with her which
started with non-consensual sex it was
pretty explosive allegations that she
was making on weibo at the beginning of
november and in my article i looked more
widely at the mistress culture and the
lifestyle that a lot of these successful
chinese men lead
an almost expectation that they have
multiple women on the side as well as
their actual wife and pen was
one such woman except the explosive part
about what she said is that it was you
know non-consensual to start with and
since then she has been heard from very
little until about last week when the
series of very bizarre proof of life
videos and images started coming out of
essentially chinese state media saying
you know what are you all fussing about
in the west she's clearly safe she look
at her she's signing tennis balls at
this
live tennis tournament or she's going to
a restaurant with her friends and her
coach so this is just all western media
hysteria except the official line
doesn't acknowledge what she accused
this uh former vice premier of doing so
it's funny line from china at the moment
where you know punch right is supposedly
safe yet nobody is acknowledging that
her statement has been censored and that
her statement should be looked into
because she accused someone of rape
and cindy when it comes to the story of
peng sharon the efforts uh by the
chinese state media to say you know she
is fine what's the fuss about
this is a particular interest in
relation to the winter olympics in
beijing can you can you talk us through
that
yeah of course i mean rumblings have
been happening for a while now about
boycotting the winter olympics uh you
know various human rights abuses in
particular uh what's happening in the
xinjiang region has led to mps in the uk
for example tim lauten to call it the
genocide games and argue that we should
be boycotting that this punch stuff is
just the latest in a series of you know
uh reasons i guess to not cooperate or
not give china the the pr coup that the
winter olympics would be and our
diplomatic presence would be so you see
a renewed push for that but of course it
also hits closer to home because penn
street is a sports woman herself and the
women's tennis association who looks
after her has said that they might
cancel china events next year and so if
that is happening where does that leave
the winter olympics uh in february next
year so we see this renewed push um and
you know the government hasn't ruled it
out essentially a boycott and the biden
administration certainly is looking at
it as well
vince um when it comes to this idea of a
potential boycott it's
if it happens you have a situation where
other countries and cindy says are
considering it what do you think will be
going through the government's minds
what's what's at stake here in terms of
a boycott of the games well it depends
what you mean by a boycott um if sports
men and sports women spontaneously
decide
that they're not going to participate
because of what's happened to paying or
wider considerations well that's their
choice and it would send quite a
powerful message because the
activity of the leading sports
personalities who've spoken up in this
case the woman's tennis association have
been very powerful in their influence
but that's quite different
from governments coming in and saying to
athletes you cannot go we forbid you
from traveling to china to participate
so what what i think people mean by
boycott
is what's now being called a diplomatic
boycott but i'd struggle to see what
would be the point of this
i mean not having a few ambassadors
turning up to the opening ceremony i
mean it's neither here nor there
um
but imposing a boycott on the athletics
world i think would be a very big step
and a very dangerous one would not
reflect well on us
we had experience of this if you
remember the moscow olympics when the
retaliation with the atlantic atlanta
olympics it simply had the effect of
diminishing international sport it was
bad for the participants bad for
spectators did absolutely nothing
whatever to improve relationships
between countries so it depends what we
mean whether this is a voluntary
withdrawal by sports people or something
imposed in a rather clumsy way by
western governments to make a propaganda
point
cindy if if we were to see a diplomatic
boycott which i think sounds like the
more likely option and it'd be very
drastic to ban athletes i think a lot of
people at home didn't really notice a
diplomat boycott um how would the
chinese government see it
well this is a very interesting thing i
i mean frankly i'm not sure because we
saw from the 2008 beijing olympics how
much stock they put into
the pr coup that that was so much money
was spent it was incredibly well
choreographed um you know thousands of
chinese dancers and actors and musicians
enrolled into that and it was seen in
china as a way of you know china
announcing that it's coming back onto
the world stage having you know come
seven years after the wto accession
winter olympics in general are not as
important as as viewers know um so you
know does this matter in the same way um
but you know i would have thought that
they would if they wanted to save face
because it looks like the biden
administrator might boycott it they
might say you know because of covet you
don't have to come you know you're going
to have to quarantine for four weeks
because china's borders are still not
open but what's interesting is that last
week they announced that putin actually
is going to the winter olympics so i
think the chinese state does care and it
does want it to be a success so you know
vince asks what's the point i mean i
guess the point is just to not give them
face uh and to you know take a stand on
human rights abuses that you think you
can't you know have this kind of
diplomatic relations you can't give the
kind of pr coup to a government that
some argue is genocidal
and vince how do you think the
government is doing when it comes to
that relationship with china because we
saw a cop 26 an effort to bring china in
um there was a sense that actually you
have to work with china particularly
when it comes to those climate targets
if you're going to have the impact but
yet we are hearing a lot of negative
comments about china the new foreign
secretary liz trust has taken on quite a
hawkish tone
well i'm very much for engagement where
possible obviously there are a lot of
difficulties
uh differences in values difference in
system uh but you know there are so many
things we have to do with china i mean
you mentioned cop
and the
statement statement with kerry and the
chinese negotiator was one of the best
things that came out of it about you
know pandemic management this uh a very
alarming proliferation of nuclear
weapons within china and internationally
i mean these are things we have to talk
to them about
um not to mention the fact that you know
the world economy is highly integrated
you know leading western companies
um are deepening their relationship with
china at the present time they're not
pulling out so you know what they're
part of the the world system and we have
to talk to them and nothing could be
worse than just saying we refuse to talk
to you because we don't like a certain
aspect of your regime completely foolish
and counterproductive but you know there
are ways in which individual westerners
the sportsmen the sporting associations
which have a great deal of soft power
um can communicate their disapproval um
and if peng
for example
doesn't appear at the australian open
which i think is six days before the
winter olympics it's quite possible that
that sporting bodies will take it into
their own hands to to make a
demonstration of feeling and that's a
much better way of doing it i mean i
rather identify with the
views of lord coe sebastian ko
our great olympian who made the point
that
you know international sporting events
like the london olympics have their own
important
message about
you know completely global system and
global participation and we shouldn't
allow
politicians for you know short-term
tactical reasons to ruin it
and cindy do you agree with that in the
sense that uh if peng's story has become
very pivotal to i suppose the chinese
government china's standing when it
comes to the olympics if she isn't for
example that at that australian open it
is going to start to raise alarm bells
and lead to not even a
government-ordered sanction but just
general and you know more condemnation
from lots of places which is probably
harder for the china chinese government
to tackle than a few diplomats not
turning up
yeah i think that's one of the
interesting things about this story is
that it has so much cut through and it
has so much attention and you know
front-page news in a way that a lot of
china's other um transgressions don't
get the same attention you know it's
quite interesting that for example the
people who want to boycott the beijing
winter olympics talk about the uyghurs
and and and the and the internment camps
but you know that hasn't had nearly as
much cut through as one tennis player
going missing um but i think that way
before the australian open we're going
to see this pantry story sizzle out and
i say that very cynically because i
think that penn is not going to pursue
her allegations i think
she's clearly under some kind of house
or arrest at the moment when life
returns to normal for her in the next
few months because she hasn't done
anything wrong she's she's only made
these allegations and i think that the
chinese state by co-opting her social
network as we saw with her coach and her
friends in these videos you know i think
they can get her to basically drop the
claims
and go back to pursuing something of her
careers i i think that by february next
year this story will be gone because
accepting our memories of course but i
don't think penn will be actively you
know in trouble or pursuing any of it
because that's just how this kind of
thing works in china um i guess to
vince's point about you know
do the olympics hold a different
perspective i mean i just it just
depends on what the chinese think of it
right i mean the people in china will
think this is the west or this is the
world recognizing china and maybe that's
a recognition that western politicians
don't want to give so that
politicization may be inevitable
and just finally vince when it comes to
the
beijing games
we saw uh with the london olympics uh
ultimately that was not the winter
olympics and as cindy says the winter
limits can have less significance um but
how important is it to a host country
when they do an event like this is it
really a tool for soft power well i i'm
sure they hope it is just just as when
we had the uh olympics in london there
was a hope that it would reflect well on
the uk as in as indeed it did so you
know these things do matter to an extent
but you know it can go badly um you know
a recollection of the greek olympics
would have just i think disorganization
lack of preparation the the russian
winter olympic games in sochi were an
embarrassment you know people
realize that the russians have put on a
massively exaggerated show and vast
amounts of money were wasted it didn't
reflect well on them at all so yeah
there is the potential for
a self-power advantage but it's um i
think probably not quite as great as
the chinese officials believe but but
going back to the original question
about
the significance of this single tennis
player i mean the fact that powerful men
can assault
women and believe they can get away with
it and because it's not unique to china
when president trump had a bit of a
track record here i mean what what is
significant about the chinese case is
that the way the state mobilized behind
one of their own a very powerful figure
and tried to hush this up and that's why
continued exposure
which will happen if the sporting bodies
continue to press and if there is
continued agitation around the
australian open i mean that's the kind
of thing i think it really matters
thanks cindy thanks vince
finally what makes a classic in this
week's magazine henry elliott an editor
at penguin classics wonders what makes a
book stand the test of time
to discuss sam and henry join me now
henry to start what do you think the
characteristics of a classic book are
can we even come up with any
well gosh i think that term classic is
really tricky to pin down and i used to
think that you know there were some
characteristics you could pick out to
define a classic you know maybe would
have to have literally quality
uh maybe it would have to have had some
historical significance maybe it was a
great bestseller in its day or it
changed the course of a genre or started
a new one or maybe um it has to have an
enduring reputation people still need to
be talking about it for it to be called
the classic but the trouble is with all
these rules i actually you know you can
always find um exceptions to the rules
and and none of them quite work and for
me the best definition of what a classic
is is the one which ezra pound came up
with in the 1930s when he said that a
classic has a certain eternal and
irrepressible freshness it's something
to do with the reading experience when
you read a classic you know it's got
that it's still alive after all the time
and all the space it's traveled through
sam do you agree with that can you think
of any uh
similar characteristics that come to
mind i do no i think i think that point
actually
i mean the very obvious thing that i
think most people would say about
classics which i think more or less
holds is that they so-called stand the
test of time
and
pounds quote nods to that with that idea
that it's it's an eternal freshness i
mean obviously
you know any good work of literature is
fresh on reading um but you know lots of
them go off after 100 years
and i think that
really i mean
the sense of a classic i think has been
generally that it's
something that survives and
of course it started out being something
that survived and it's turned into a
publisher's marketing term um because
obviously classic has a sort of ring of
approbation about it as i think sheamus
heaney said you know poet is a praise
word and so is classic
um
so
you know it has acquired this sort of
marketing sense i mean i think
the point about about the
the way that classics influence things
is maybe worth taking into account
because so many of them
are so odd and suey generous
so when you take some moby dick it's a
very very very bizarre book and so is
tristram shandy both of them are
acknowledged classics but at the same
time both of them have sort of
you know
many years later than they were
published kind of influenced various
styles and ideas
and ways of presenting things so that
kind of massively textural
um you know halfway between a novel and
an encyclopedia and a myth
maybe dick format admittedly the bible
got there first but maybe dick took that
into fiction and
you know tristram shandy people have
been wrestling with the ideas of
tristram shandy in the same way they've
been wrestling with the ideas in muscle
duchenne's urinal for years and years
and years on
you're absolutely right and i think um
uh
you know i think that's always the case
when you read a book which is an
established classic it's always stranger
and sort of odder than you were
expecting it's you know
you
almost by definition you approach a
classic with a preconception of what
it's going to be like because it has
this reputation it has an aura around it
and then when you actually read the
words it's often much more bizarre than
you would well it is that that old
chestnut doesn't know that you know
genius creates the taste by which it
will be received and
you know so many of these
extraordinary works that have now become
completely canonical are
works that actually just
created
you know created a sensibility that
allowed them to be understood yeah i
completely agree and it often takes time
for a classic to be acknowledged i mean
you know you take a look like the great
gatsby which was practically ignored at
the time and fitzgerald died thinking
his work had been forgotten and now
that's considered perhaps the greatest
work of american literature from the
20th century but i think it's
interesting you use the word canonical
because this is some something that i've
been thinking about recently that i
think there used to be a real
association between that word classic
and the idea of an established canon a
kind of received canon that's imposed
from
that's inherited from above and was
imposed by critics and scholars
and i
feel that right now we're at a bit of a
tipping point that we're moving beyond
the idea of an established cannon
in a way today it feels almost
ridiculous that there could be a single
list that
comprises the essential books for every
reader in the world i see the job of a
publisher like penguin to be much more
about mapping out
this incredible literary landscape sort
of scouting the territory and
signposting these amazing uh books you
know these areas about standing natural
beauty in this kind of landscape rather
than sort of dictating saying these are
the books one should read these are the
best i don't i don't i'm not sure i
completely agree and i think we probably
agree in substance more than we would in
the way we express it but i think we
still have cannons they're probably more
plural and more complex and more
three-dimensional than they were but the
idea which is pretty fun fundamental to
the activity of literary critics and
people in my line of work ie middlebrow
book reviewers is that it's possible to
say that some books are better than
others and that some are more
influential than others
and obviously
the canon as it was
you know for the last 50 60 70 years
we've been
you know complaining i mean when i was
at university
the sort of running joke was you know
dwems dead white european males and we'd
have these conversations about the
beards of the great western authors and
you know
um and the idea that the canon as it was
constituted in the you know i guess
early 20th century late 19th century
was
exclusionary and
very kind of narrow and monocular and
focus basically on old dead bearded
blokes um
but i think the idea of a cannon or
several cannons that relate to each
other
is in no way dead um i mean it's simply
it's simply sort of changed um and i
don't think that's that's the worst
thing i mean i quite like the absolute
definitiveness though of someone like fr
leavers who i think begins a great
tradition with was the effect of the
great tradition consists of
george eliot henry james joseph conrad
possibly jane austen and one book by
dickens and that's it
and henry when we're looking to the
books coming out today
um do you think it is possible for
critics perhaps people such as sam to
look at those books and declare that
this is going to be a classic of
tomorrow
i think it's really difficult i think
it's very difficult i mean i think this
is where the word classic as a marketing
tool comes in and you know i think if
things are acclaimed instant classic i
think that's
that's sort of hopeful thinking really i
mean
i think
as we've said really the thing that has
to happen is time has to pass to see
whether a book can endure and become a
classic
and so all we can have is a kind of best
guess
and i think that's very tricky my my
sort of gut feeling is that it's going
to be as sam you were saying it's going
to be those authors who've changed the
direction of literature who've done
something new something original which
will go on to influence others in the
years to come and so
i guess you know looking around at who's
writing today i guess that could be
colson whitehead or maybe hillary
mantell um
chimamanda ngozi and dici but
perhaps
um
[Music]
but very hard to very hard to pull
things out i'd say yeah i tend to file
future classic under the
factories things that reviewers say in
the hopes of being quoted on the
paperback department and
was that
from their copy when i can find it well
sam just as a difficult final question
to you and if you had to have a best
guess of what you think the classics of
tomorrow that any that come to mind i
mean i wonder you know if you look at a
book such as the sally rooney books
something that seems to dominate lots of
discourse um you know in the in the
media across the world do you think
sally rooney is gonna be an author of
classics and you know 50 years time 100.
well i slightly recuse myself from that
question on the grounds my answer to the
last one um i think what i could say to
sort of sidestep it is
the books that make a lot of noise in
the media are not necessarily the ones
that are going to live and
you know an instance i've been looking
into the history of children's
literature and you know what was selling
then and what we now think you know
alice in wonderland is you know instant
that was the classic that's the turning
point and in some ways that's true but
what that ignores is that the now almost
completely forgotten bonkers imperialist
adventure teller
um g.a henty was actually the person
really making the market in children's
literature at the time and so
you know the
fuss in the media certainly does not a
future classic make
sam henry thanks for joining
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon so
you never miss an episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you